cuando cayó la unión soviética sergei
krikalev se encontraba a 350 kilómetros
por encima de su país de origen
inicialmente su misión debía durar 5
meses pero el astronauta permaneció casi
un año en la estación mir su labor
mantener con vida la joya de la
tecnología soviética
rusia tenía una necesidad absoluta por
economizar los lanzamientos del cohete
sayús y como debía haber alguien dentro
de la estación para hacer el
mantenimiento se le pidió a kyrie cal
efe que extendiera su estado
en rusia que vi caler se convirtió en el
héroe que salvó la estación espacial en
occidente fue visto como un astronauta
abandonado en el espacio por una
superpotencia en declive
sergei krikalyov
se habló mucho al respecto porque es una
historia romántica ese pobre muchacho
estaba ahí arriba perdido pero yo lo
conozco personalmente es una persona muy
serena y acepto por completo esa
condición sin ningún problema
cuando sergei krikalev regreso a la
tierra el 25 de marzo de 1992 a bordo de
una cápsula dos hoyos como esta su país
había desaparecido
aterrizó en kazajistán un estado
entonces independiente su pasaporte
había vencido a su ciudad de origen
leningrado ahora se llamaba san
petesburgo y su generoso sueldo de
seiscientos rublos ya no valía nada
tras la caída de la unión soviética
rusia al borde de la ruina heredó el
programa espacial
su problema era el dinero de repente
dejó de haber un presupuesto espacial y
la llegada al poder de boris yelstin es
realmente significó darle la espalda a
esa herencia de la grandeza soviética
porque se consideró que era un
desperdicio así que el ámbito espacial
que era una de las puntas de lanza de la
ideología enfrentó muchas dificultades
una verdadera habilidad corría el riesgo
de perderse y occidente se movilizó
estadounidenses europeos canadienses
japoneses y rusos entraron en la era de
la cooperación y conformación de la
estación espacial internacional
[Música]
los estadounidenses le propusieron a los
rusos integrarse al programa tuvieron la
oportunidad de aportar mucha experiencia
con estaciones espaciales porque ellos
se dedicaron a de las estaciones
espaciales desde comienzos de los años
al comienzo la cooperación fue difícil
principalmente durante los años 95 y 96
pero después hubo una verdadera mejoría
cuando llegó el momento de los primeros
vuelos a la iss y los primeros
astronautas desembarcaron en la estación
espacial internacional el 31 de octubre
del 2000 el cohete ruso soyuz y las
naves espaciales estadounidenses
realizaron viajes entre la tierra y la
estación espacial durante 11 años hasta
que el programa asia abandonó
considerado demasiado caro y peligroso
en 2011 rusia quedó en el monopolio de
los pueblos tripulados hacia la estación
espacial el precio del tiquete podría
alcanzar los 79 millones de dólares con
cuatro vuelos al año y tres astronautas
a bordo suficiente para que el programa
ruso sobreviviera pero todo cambió en
2020 con la llegada de un nuevo actor la
empresa privada estadounidense spacex
en
esto
los estadounidenses también querían
tener acceso a la estación espacial
internacional iss al espacio hasta ese
momento eeuu dependía de rúsia para
poder acceder a la estación
[Música]
la estación espacial se enfrentó
entonces a una competencia privada pero
también actores como china e india los
rusos tuvieron que reinventarse a pesar
de tener un presupuesto limitado los dos
mil millones de dólares diez veces menos
que el presupuesto de la nasa eran un
monto insuficiente para participar en el
proyecto de la estación orbital lunar
dirigido por los estadounidenses para
renunciar a 50 años de presencia en el
espacio no era una opción al
rusia se vio totalmente rechazada y
dejada al margen frente al mundo
occidental por eso hubo un impulso
nacionalista y un acercamiento con china
que también ocurrió en otros sectores en
los que china y rúsia conformaron un
frente común
el espacio está vinculado a la
geopolítica así que la posición
geopolítica es muy compleja y también
muy importante los rusos tienen la
posibilidad de cooperar con china
cooperar con eeuu o cooperar con ambos
con sus ambiciones civiles y científicas
por el suelo rusia se volvió a
concentrar en el corazón de su proyecto
el aspecto militar el pasado 15 de
noviembre un lanzamiento de misil
pulverizó el satélite obsoleto fue una
operación que otras grandes potencias ya
han hecho en contravención de todos los
tratados fue una demostración eso es
seguro una demostración tecnológica una
demostración de que es necesario contar
con ellos también quieren volver a estar
en el centro del escenario donde se
habla mucho sobre china pero mucho menos
sobre rusia no aparecieron del lado de
los buenos pero si del lado de los que
saben hacer cosas
hoy en día la mayor parte de los
sistemas de armas dependen de los
satélites si la órbita terrestre se
vuelve un campo de batalla rusia no
tiene contemplado ceder terreno
[Música]